massive hurricane Florence is set to
slam into the Carolinas potentially
causing catastrophic damage and somehow
it's now president Trump's fault
The Washington Post out with an op-ed
titled another hurricane is about to
batter our coasts Trump is complicit
according to the post because President
Trump doesn't bend over backwards to
support climate change
he's now to blame and I go to our
resident climate change expert Greg
Gutfeld this always drives me crazy okay
I'll start with two facts and then have
an overall assessment of this situation
okay okay so from ninety closure ears
he's gonna talk okay so from 1915 to
1965 that's fifty-one years that there
were 19 major hurricanes now if you go
fifty-one years from their 1966 to 2016
you've only had seven so that's 37% is
frequent so if there's a rising climate
change and fewer of these major
hurricanes there goes your theory but
there is something you know there's an
increase in damage over time with these
hurricanes but that's not due to the
storm intensity it's because we're
increasing infrastructure in coastal
areas so you can blame not a global
warming but you could blame the builders
for building in areas where their storms
but I will say this to be fair because I
no want disagree sympathy the jury's
probably still out on this stuff who's
gonna take time to look at everything
the big problem is is what I call the
Trump floater you know when you go to a
bar and you order like a whiskey with a
Bailey's floater or a Meyers floater
every story every stories now a drink
every stories a drink with a Trump
floater so it's like whether you're
whether it's about like yesterday 9/11
or hurricanes or or any kind of any kind
of a vet psychological disorders
depression can't sleep can't sleep it's
Trump so everything now has a Trump
angle it's a it's everything is a drink
with the Trump floater and it's because
people people in the media have Trump on
the brain and they're using that instead
of their brain why are all your
analogies about bars and bathrooms
one always leads to the other I came
prepared dress you as mr. Williams
because I found out how old you are
water was gonna be a very statistical
type of segment
I brought a chart can we see the chart
please in the control look at this chart
America the largest decline in co2
emissions in the world look at us all
the way up at the top we're reducing our
co2 and got China's like we're China the
European Union Canada they're increasing
their co2 so first year the trunk
president's presidency co2 is down now
on explain that one maybe maybe you kept
your mouth shut in the hot air you know
you have us as the number-one emitter of
these gases and you say we make some
steps to pull back and therefore
everybody else is to blame I don't get
it we're not we're decreasing you are
increasing because they have an
increasing base of middle-class people
factories and the like they're still
gaining a middle-class weirdness gaining
a middle-class they are there so cannot
the EU but China a lot of what they call
the BRIC nations you know Brazil India
they're building up Jesse so the idea is
that the United States as a successful
economy with a large middle class would
set an example about the need for
reducing co2 nowhere that's why it's our
what they here's what the Washington
Post editorial board said guess who has
just signed legislation to allow the you
know the expansion of methane gas in our
release in our country Donald Trump
Donald Trump and Republican orthodoxy
has become aware the contrarians we
don't believe these scientists we don't
believe any of this about increasing
temperatures and Greg there's been
increasing temperatures over the last
dozen years in the world while it's
increasing temperatures under my collar
cuz you're making me very angry
the implication is then that the United
States should take measures which often
frankly are job-killing measures
hundreds of thousands of people in this
country lose their jobs because it hurts
energy production and these other
sources of energy energy production are
not yet ready to roll and compete with
coal and otherwise and other countries
just get to do nothing and once we
assess we pay when you're thinking a
little that was what the Paris Accord
was no no it wasn't and I think Ryan is
a little off there because the reality
is that now alternative energy
development has produced more jobs than
let's say coal mine oh yeah there's tons
of windmill jobs out there which are
which are power stations right Dana
let's get some facts here this was about
Donald Trump and pre blaming him for the
hurricane I mean it used to be the
hurricane comes in Obama's
administration Hurricane sandy was
blamed on Republicans as well for
hurricanes I talked to Charlie hurt
yesterday one of our foxnews
contributors he lives in the path of the
hurricane and he said that people they
are still talking about Hurricane
Camille from 1969 when they had it was a
terrible hurricane and that was before
these Rises I do think that America
plays an important role here and that is
because we are innovative and we have a
growing economy right now that means you
can invest in new technology so that you
can get to the point that your dad is
making which is can we continue to
figure out a way to decrease them I
would say from a political standpoint
the Republican Party could stand to talk
about this a little bit more they have a
good position that they you know you're
gonna lose an entire younger generation
if you don't try to talk to them about
this it's what you can't win you can't
win and you could you can well it's you
could just not try right well the thing
is right now what's happening is the
Liberals the left of the Liberals they
have replaced global warming with Trump
used to be the global warming
cause war shark attacks and depression
but now they just said no Trump causes
everything bad and so now we have to do
our best to somehow reduce the amount of
Trump in the atmosphere and you can
support innovation I think that's a
great idea an invasion problem is
but the problem is that they that they
want first of all United States can't do
this by ourselves if we if we do great
things when it comes to two other energy
sources and the rest of the world
doesn't follow suit it's not going to
accomplish anything and also if these
other areas are not ready to compete
with coal I'm all for it I'm all for
those innovations but if they're not
ready
you can't kill one industry then also
take coal away from have nowhere to go
nowhere to work so it has to that's why
the framers remember when Hillary
Clinton said to the coal miners you know
we can help you move on find new kinds
of jobs retrain it was a business do is
help people move on what's your point
it's not like you're making the case for
the Paris climate deal because I know
that that locks in other countries to
make commensurate sacrifice and the
methane piece is a little bit more
complicated than how Juan described it
we have to tease so I would just tell me
about it thing is whatever shoes Melania
wears to the hurricane ravaged states
they better not be too expensive because
she's going to get attacked